Transcription: Louise ARNAUD
Relecteur: eric vautier
Countdown : le compte à rebours.
Compter en sens contraire.
Compter de la fin vers un début.
Compter de la fin vers une autre fin.
Compter de la fin vers une mort.
Compter de la mort vers une autre mort.
Compter de la mort vers une naissance,
ou plutôt une renaissance,
ou plutôt un renouveau.
C’est un peu l’impasse philosophique
dans laquelle je me suis retrouvé
à tourner en rond,
à me demander ce que
je viendrais bien vous raconter.
Dans cette impasse philosophique,
j’ai tourné en rond,
un peu d’ailleurs, comme la planète Terre.
J’ai trouvé dans cette impasse
philosophique
des sources d’innovation incroyables.
J’ai trouvé dans cette impasse
philosophique
des révolutions technologiques
extraordinaires.
Mais j’y ai aussi trouvé
des sujets de conférences
où les masques sont de rigueur
pour les gaz à effet de serre.
J’ai trouvé, dans cette conférence,
que l’écart,
la distanciation sociale entre les plus
avancés et les moins avancés
semblait se mettre au rythme
du trou de la couche d’ozone.
Dans cette impasse philosophique, à force
de compter, ou plutôt de décompter,
j’ai fini par tomber sur une histoire,
celle d’un homme, que dis-je,
celle de l’Homme.
L’Homme que le Créateur
fit centre de tout,
à qui il confia une maison,
et dans cette maison, il est ressource
et il est producteur de ressources.
Sa seule mission est
d’entretenir les ressources
sur les principes de proportion,
d’équilibre et d’harmonie.
Ainsi, la maison serait
ce que l’homme serait.
La maison ferait ce que l'homme serait.
Mais...
à force de compter,
ou plutôt de décompter,
il faut dire que le Créateur, dans
l’unique commandement qu’il lui donna,
lui demanda de prendre soin de ce
qu’il lui donnait de plus cher : la vie.
Une part de lui-même.
Des éléments appelés
divinités : eau, terre, air et feu.
Mais là encore, à force de compter
ou plutôt de décompter,
l’homme finit par s’oublier.
Il finit par opposer
les divinités entre elles.
Il se servit du feu pour brûler la terre.
Il se sert de la terre pour souiller l’eau
et se sert de l’eau pour détruire l’air.
Il tomba malade.
On lui diagnostiqua une maladie étrange.
Une grosse fièvre appelée
réchauffement climatique.
Réchauffement climatique à force
de dérèglements de comportements.
Le feu, source de chaleur et de lumière,
s’employa à l’embraser,
s’employa à le pousser
dans  une obscurité extrême.
L’air, l’énergie,
s’employa à entretenir des guerres
intestines, des guerres fratricides
et laissa siffler les balles
pour entretenir nos mines.
L’eau, source de jouvence,
l’élément régénérateur, semblait vouloir
tout inonder et s’employa à l’étouffer.
La Terre, élément nourricier,
s’employa à devenir capricieuse,
cynique même.
Mais à force de décompter,
ou plutôt de compter,
il vit
que la mort imminente pousse à agir.
Il se retourna vers ses divinités
pour recouvrer la santé.
Celles-ci lui indiquèrent le chemin
de la grandeur et de l’humilité,
la grandeur de ce que fit le Créateur,
la grandeur d’être le centre de tout,
le centre de la maison, le centre de qui
tout part et le centre vers qui tout part.
L’humilité, à l’image de cette immense
étendue d’eau,
capable de tout engloutir,
qui, dans la rage de sa vague, finit tout
de même par se prosterner à ses pieds.
Un peu d’ailleurs, comme la mère,
suppliant le ciel et le créateur
de sauver son enfant malade.
Ainsi renaîtra l'homme nouveau.
L’homme recyclé.
Ainsi l’homme recouvrera la santé.
Il retrouvera sur ce chemin
de la grandeur et de l’humilité,
les principes de proportion,
d’harmonie et d’équilibre.
Le compte à rebours pourra enfin
se faire d’une fin vers un début,
d’un début vers un début, vers la vie.
Le chemin de l'espoir.
L’espoir, je l’ai trouvé, en ce qui me
concerne, dans le déchet.
Nous en produisons beaucoup,
nos sociétés en produisent,
nos gouvernants en produisent,
nos écoles en produisent.
Des déchets de tous genres.
Le déchet, je le veux
plutôt comme une arme
de construction massive,
une âme de construction
d’innovation sociale.
C’est ainsi que je crois que nous ferons
et nous porterons le message qui est clair
et ce pour quoi nous nous battons.
Alors permettez-moi de le dire
très directement et très franchement :
tant que j’ai faim, tant que ma retraite
sera synonyme de mort lente,
de mort imminente, tant que
mes enfants auront faim,
tant que je n’aurai pas d’espoir
pour mes petits-enfants,
tant que ma mère sera obligée
de vendre devant ma porte
pour me payer ma scolarité,
pardonnez-moi de le dire,
je n’ai rien à foutre de la planète.
Parce que le créateur
fit de moi centre de tout,
le centre de qui tout part
et le centre vers qui tout part.
Avant de construire ma maison, la ville
durable, je dois construire l'homme.
C'est de lui qu'il s'agit.
Je vous remercie.
(Applaudissements)